it was an announcement most people in
Sri Lanka had been waiting for IMF staff
and the authorities have reached staff
level agreement to support Sri Lanka's
economic policies with a 48-month
Arrangement under the so-called extended
fund facility
of about 2.9 billion US Dollars Sri
Lanka asked for IMF help in March after
its economy phase collapse and it ran
out of money for food medicine cooking
gas and fuel
tens of thousands of Sri Lankans were
forced to queue for Essentials
the crisis led to months of protests
that forced former prime minister
Mahindra rajapaksa to resign and his
brother president Kota bear to flee the
country
news of an agreement on a bailout has
brought a sense of relief to many here
in Sri Lanka but some observers say it
may be premature to celebrate We Stand
ready to
put this agreement to our management and
then to our if management approves it to
then put it forward to the executive
board as soon as these conditions that I
mentioned are satisfied so we we do need
to await now for these conditions to
take place the main condition is for Sri
Lanka to come up with a workable plan to
pay back the money it owes
the IMF is also asked to increase taxes
an end to subsidize electricity and Fuel
and stringent efforts to Stamp Out
corruption the government has already
begun implementing some of those reforms
through an interim budget
tax management must play an important
role in increasing Revenue including
increasing tax collection tax compliance
and preventing tax evasion I propose
making it mandatory for everyone over 18
years to register with the Inland
Revenue Department irrespective of their
annual income and tax Hall Days
2.9 billion dollars from the IMF will
make a huge difference to Sri Lanka but
in order to secure those funds it must
come up with a proper plan of how it
will pay its mountainous debts for the
people of Sri Lanka that can't come fast
enough Fernandez Al Jazeera Colombo